in 2015 the Irish economy grew by an
unprecedented
25% in just 12 short months it achieved
the previous 12 years worth of growth
needless to say that doesn't happen
anywhere the global average that year
was
3.1% even China and India could only
manage seven and
eight and yet 2015 wasn't the only time
Ireland exceeded all possible
expectations 6 years later its economy
grew by nearly
14% today Ireland is the second richest
country in the world with a population
over 1 million its per capita GDP of
$14,000 is 36% higher than the United
States even more impressive is how
recent all this is 30 years ago Ireland
lagged slightly behind the European
average now it's almost three times
wealthier in the 70s 80s and '90s it
received billions of Euros in subsidies
from the EU today it contributes
billions of
Euros back then thousands fled the
country in search of greener
pastures but since 1996 the flow of
migration has reversed skilled
professionals from around the globe now
reloc to the island every year for all
these reasons Ireland has been called
the Celtic tiger in reference to the
rapid rise of the four Asian tigers Hong
Kong Taiwan Singapore and South
Korea there's just one tiny problem it's
not
real these numbers are all real and
these facts are technically true but
what they imply is not the Irish
economic Miracle is an elaborate
carefully preserved illusion to see why
we need to roll back the clock to 1980
the year everything
changed sponsored by givewell the
independent nonprofit whose rigorous
charity research allows you and I to
make the largest possible
impact in 1980 Apple became the first
foreign tech company to manufacture in
Ireland according to CEO Tim Cook it saw
in the country quote a community rich
with talent and one that could
accommodate growth and in the official
corporate version of History that's
where the story ends Apple took a chance
on this small developing nation and the
two grew handin hand Apple's press
release for its 40th anniversary
repeatedly refers to its Irish family
and Community but the timing tells a
different
story Ireland has pursued
business-friendly policies since at
least 1956 when it began offering 10
years of generous tax breaks to foreign
manufacturers but after joining what
would become the European Union in
1973 it agreed to phase out those
incentive starting in
1981 Apple in other words snuck in the
door right at the 11th Hour securing for
itself a full decade of tax breaks
during the company's most vulnerable era
it was during this period that Steve
Jobs was replaced by the former CEO of
Pepsi John Scully who initiated a major
restructuring the company was losing
billions of dollars and bankruptcy was
on the
horizon Ireland wasn't doing much better
nearly a quarter of its population was
unemployed so as its 10-year window
began to close Apple approached the
country with an offer it would funnel
nearly all of its worldwide Revenue into
Ireland but it was only willing to pay
an effective tax rate of less than
2% and while 2% may not be much that was
2% the country would otherwise never see
in return Apple would have a safe place
to stash its International
profits Ireland desperate for whatever
cash it could get its hands on accepted
this opening bid without
negotiation the only thing left to do
was write the tax code to make this
Arrangement legal it worked backwards
crafting rules that would artificially
produce the 2% figure and just like that
apple had set its own tax
rate now the reason this was possible
was IRS form
8832 form 8832 doesn't look like much
it's a pretty unassuming three pages but
it completely transformed the American
Tax
landscape before 8832 us corporations
were required to pay us taxes on their
worldwide income whether their bananas
were sold in South Carolina or South
Africa until recently that rate was
35% after 1996 US corporations could
simply check a box allowing them to
avoid paying this tax as long as their
money stayed
overseas a year later Ireland passed a
similar law now companies only had to
pay tax in the country where their ke
decisions were made in practice anywhere
they wanted or even better nowhere at
all the trick was that no one was
enforcing
consistency in America Apple could argue
its subsidiary was genuinely Irish over
in Ireland Apple could simultaneously
argue it was really based somewhere else
like
Bermuda that was step one apple had
created a low tax Irish subsidiary but
it still needed to move its
International profit into that company
when you walk into an Apple store in
Munich and buy an iPhone that profit
needs to somehow end up in apple Ireland
not Apple Germany the solution was
intellectual property IP is the perfect
vehicle for tax avoidance because it's a
extremely valuable who could argue that
the Apple logo isn't worth a fortune and
yet be extremely difficult to Value
who's to say it's worth 1 trillion and
not
1.2 by moving around these Priceless yet
intangible patents logos and other
trademarks Apple could move its profit
too it simply gave the rights to use its
IP outside of the Americas to its Irish
subsidiary then whenever it sold an
iPhone in Munich for say $100 Apple
Germany would have to pay Apple Ireland
let's say $98 for use of its
trademark thus 98% of the profit would
be attributed to low tax
Ireland but there's a wrinkle officially
Ireland's corporate tax rate is
12.5% recall that to reduce this to less
than 2% Apple declared its Irish
subsidiary a tax resident of somewhere
like Bermuda where the rate was even
lower except Ireland imposes a special
20% tax on transfers to known tax Havens
like Bermuda Apple therefore needed to
transfer its money through an
intermediary another company this time
in the Netherlands to which the first
Irish company would sublicense its
IP next Apple created a second Irish
company which sublicensed the IP from
the Dutch one lastly this second Irish
company would license its IP to Apple
subsidiaries across the
globe now all together you walk in into
a German Apple store and buy an iPhone
Apple Germany argues that most of the
value of that sale was derived from
intellectual property property it
doesn't own therefore Apple Germany pays
a royalty to that second Irish company
the second Irish company also doesn't
own anything it too pays a fee to the
Dutch company the Dutch company does the
same forwarding most of the money it's
just received onto the first Irish
company finally the first Irish Company
claims its key decisions are made in a
small Caribbean country where the
corporate tax rate is at or near
0%
voila Apple pioneered this strategy
which became known as the double Irish
with a Dutch sandwich but it was by no
means the only Corporation to take
advantage Google Microsoft and Facebook
all did the same during the '90s and
early 2000s us multinationals made an
increasing share of their profit profits
overseas billions of dollars of which
made their way to Ireland and while most
people assume some level of tax
Shenanigans the astonishing scale of
this effort largely flew under the radar
for years much of what we know today is
only thanks to Independent researchers
and academics like Emma Clancy Brian oo
and Kieran
Allen then in 2013 as the public began
taking notice the US Senate held
high-profile hearings attending by Tim
Cook with the world's attention focused
on Ireland the country feigned
innocence Apple had simply exploited a
loophole never mind that it had
expressly written its tax code to
produce these results the double Irish
was no more it announced Irish companies
would now be taxed in if you can believe
it
Ireland Apple's first Irish subsidiary
could no longer claim to be a tax
resident of say Bermuda
but not to worry generally speaking tax
treaties supersede local laws companies
therefore could simply replace Bermuda
with a country that shared a tax treaty
with Ireland for Apple that country was
Jersey the British crown dependency with
a population of just over 100,000 people
problem
solved now it should be clear by now
that Ireland is in fact a tax Haven the
question is is its economic success real
recall that Ireland is one of the
richest countries on the planet with a
per capita GDP of over
$100,000 and that its economy grew by
25% in 2015
alone critics of its tax regime argue
that this is all just a statistical
Mirage that the country is little more
than a Bermuda Bahamas or British Virgin
Islands with
castles consider for example example
what happened in
2015 Irish workers weren't suddenly 25%
more productive nor did Irish companies
export 25% more Goods no what really
happened is that when Ireland closed the
double Irish loophole it opened a new
one starting in 2015 companies could
subtract from their tax bill the full
cost of any IP they purchased so what
did companies do they bought a whole lot
of Ip from themselves of course
companies like apple transferred an
estimated $270 billion worth of
trademarks and patents into their Irish
subsidiaries and since on paper
trademarks are no different from oil or
refrigerators Ireland's GDP grew by
25% this is what Skeptics mean when they
say its economy isn't real even worse
while the benefits aren't real they
argue there are real
costs the dominance of foreign
multinationals in tiny Ireland has
contributed to a housing crisis that
makes americaas look tame by comparison
between 1991 and 2007 Dublin home prices
increased by 4
129% according to these
researchers secondly the Irish economy
is incredibly dependent on a very small
number of American
corporations just 10 are responsible for
60% of the country's corporate tax
receipts the top three pay about a third
of the total from the recent boom to the
busts of the Great Recession and the dot
bubble the Irish economy is fully at the
mercy of
Washington in 2021 Ireland was pressured
into signing an oecd agreement that sets
a 15% Global minimum corporate tax rate
and reallocates profits to the country
in which a sale physically occurred if
the past is any indication Ireland will
simply invent a new
loophole still the risk remains that it
will one day truly be forced to change
its ways and lose out on this revenue
and not just
Revenue as proponents of Ireland's tax
regime are quick to point out part of
the implicit bargain struck nearly 40
years ago between Apple and Ireland was
that the former provide highquality
highly paid
employment the United States along with
much of the world experienced a baby
boom following the end of World War II
20 years later these millions of young
adults joined the workforce producing
this steady 40-year rise in
employment Ireland's baby boom on the
other hand was about 30 years delayed
and much more
compressed as you can see it suddenly
had millions of young working age people
in the
1990s apple and its peers put thousands
of these 20 and 30y olds to work today
as much as 10% % of the Irish Workforce
is employed by Foreign companies nearly
all American and nearly all in Tech
Apple's 2020 press release about its
Irish Community wasn't a total smokees
screen it truly does employ more than
just
accountants even if low taxes brought
multinationals in the first place this
argument goes they've stayed for its
genuine operational
advantages indeed Ireland is now the
only English-speaking country in the EU
it's a mere 6 hours from New York and
its population is highly
educated sure Ireland is a tax Haven
they might admit but its economic
success is very
real but what both those who argue
Ireland's economy is real and those who
argue its fake misunderstand Is that
real and fake aren't
contradictory in fact these two sides of
its economy are
complimentary take for instance what
happened in
2013 shortly after the explosive US
Senate hearings the European Union
launched an investigation into Apple's
tax practices and in 2016 it concluded
that Ireland had granted it special
treatment and while it is of course
entitled to set its own tax laws as a
member of the EU it also agrees not to
Grant preferential treatment to any one
Corporation the court in a ruling that
has since been overturned and is now in
the process of a second appeal ordered
Apple to pay Ireland $14 billion in
unpaid
taxes so how did Ireland react to this
$4 billion winfall with
outrage to the confusion of many Irish
citizens their government launched an
immediate challenge to this ruling now
you might be thinking of course better
to turn down a small sum of money today
to preserve the larger flow tomorrow but
this was no small amount of money
remember Ireland is a country of just 5
million people $4 billion would have
paid for the country's entire annual
Health budgets or 7 years of
Transportation let's not forget that
lower corporate tax rates are merely an
alternative means of achieving the same
goal the Irish government like every
other government is in the business of
collecting more
taxes so why turn down so much cash
especially since in the eyes of Apple
Ireland's hands were clean it didn't
initiate the court case the EU did
because Ireland is not just a tax Haven
after all there are safer cheaper and
more secretive places to stash your
profits it isn't even the lowest tax
jurisdiction in Europe Apple could
surely find a more accommodating
government in a smaller less Democratic
Caribbean island what Ireland really
sells and and what the Caribbean can't
offer is its untarnished
reputation yes the ultr low taxes of the
Cayman Islands but without the
connotation of the Cayman
Islands here's how it works first
Ireland's real economy the one in which
real people go to work every day and fix
pipes connect servers and sell computers
creates the illusion of
legitimacy second thanks to this
illusion companies concerned about their
image like apple choose Ireland as their
tax shelter third in doing so Apple
inflates the country's economic health
creating the appearance of unbelievable
wealth fourth and finally this economic
Miracle is seized upon by those with an
agenda to lower corporate tax rates who
argue look what's possible when you're
just friendly to
businesses without the real in other
words the fake wouldn't exist and
without the fake neither would the real
in that 2013 Senate hearing Tim Cook
proudly proclaimed quote Apple does not
hold money on a Caribbean Island and
quote does not have a bank account in
the Cayman
Islands that was true and that's why
Apple chooses
Ireland the reason Ireland fought the EU
ruling was that something more important
than $4 billion was at stake something
extraordinarily valuable yet imp
possible to precisely value much like
the intellectual property Apple moves
between its
subsidiaries its
reputation in truth many of the things
we value the most are also the most
difficult to measure happiness love
creativity and doing good we all want to
do the most good but when we give to say
a charity how do we ensure that we're
making the largest possible impact well
in 2007 a few friends had that same
question and decided to start give well
they closely scrutinize all the data we
have on Charities and publish this
information on the givewell website
allowing you and I to compare some of
the over 1.5 million nonprofit
organizations in the United States that
way when we go to donate we know where
our money is going what it's doing and
who it's helping these are nonpartisan
cost-effective evidence-backed causes
like preventing malaria solving vitamin
deficiencies and incentivizing childhood
vaccines we shouldn't have to become
experts on charitable giving when we
shop for phones or cars we search for
reviews so why not Outsource that work
to charity
researchers what I like about givewell
is that they don't take any fees all
your money goes straight to the charity
of your choice they've even gone out of
their way to advise me not to disparage
other Charities which to me is a pretty
clear indicator of their values plus
right now new donors can get their
entire donation matched up to $100
before the end of the year as long as
funds last so hurry now while you still
can and go to give well.org that's give
well.org or click the link in the
description or on screen now then choose
YouTube and enter poly matter at
checkout to do twice as much
good